i have never seen ryan thompson pitch
no they haven't seen him much either
he's been in four games this season he's
a side armor
right side and a nice short hop nice
pick by jimon
and he'll go to the bag himself three
unassisted and that's the way game
two gets underway there's one out it's
grounded right toward third
first chance for joey wendell his throw
across in plenty of time and is quickly
two goals
two up two down and aaron hicks will
come to the plate and the [ __ ] is
chopped
up the middle and through to right
center field for a single
he's a board with a two out single then
carlos stan will be the better
in the ground ball off the end of the
bat right to the second baseman brandon
lau
he has it throws to first in plenty of
time and ryan thompson able to put
together
a scoreless top of the first michael
mcrae king
make his third appearance here on the
season he'll be facing austin meadows
there's a swing at a live drive toward
right center field
aaron hicks on the run reaches can't get
it and austin meadows leads off the
bottom of the first
with a double two walks in the inning
and the rays have loaded the bases
for yoshi tsutugo runners go to the
pitch inside paul four of the rays have
taken
a one-nothing lead on a bases loaded
walk to yoshi three
straight walks will get matt blake to
pitch and coach to the mound it gives
the rays just their second first inning
run of the year
ground ball grabbed by urchella goes the
short way and that will do it
to the second inning and king facing
left-handed and kevin kiermeier cut on
and missed
so kier meyer is struck out and here's
the backup catcher left-hand hitting
michael perez
1-2 cut on a miss so king gets two
straight strikeouts both on high
fastballs
chewy here is austin meadows and the
slider is did he go
yes he did third base up by randy
rosenberg
pumped him out so king comes back not
only with a one two three
but he strikes out the side fairbanks
for the walk and here we are another
moment where
he allows a base runner and i know he's
working in back-to-back days but at some
point
kevin cass keeps reiterating we've got
to get pete to get a trouble free
anecdote
another bouncer rolls away from perez on
to second goal stanton you have to be
ready to run that rolled only about five
feet away up the third baseline
the stanton was ready to go so the
yankees have the time run at second
base hit to center field stanton is at
third he'll stop right there
as kier meyer gets it in so a base hit
for glebe torres yankees have runners on
the corners with one out
well here is luke voight it's sharply
and through for base hit
stanton scores around second on his way
to third is torrez kermeyer's throw
gonna be close the tag he is out at
third base
wendell with a tag on torres kermier
with the assist from right center
it's a long throw and there are two away
but the yankees have tied the game
it's low ball four and the bases are
loaded the second time today
the rays have walked to fill the bases
gotta think avalon was being careful
with diaz
he does get the lefty lefty matchup he
wants but it's austin meadows
soft looper shallow left dropping in a
hurry here comes tachman
it falls through a base head adamus
scores tiermeyer scores
and meadows delivers the rays take a
three-to-one lead
low of all four in the bases are loaded
six walks by yankees pitching and jose
martinez is coming up
up the middle the mayhew
gets martinez and that will do it well
while we were away
we kind of knew this was going to happen
about three yankees got flipped
and uh aaron boone finally had enough
and uh he had his say
with the umpires and he really had a
saying you feel for him because he's
trying to be socially distant and he's
trying to keep the mask up over his nose
here's joey wendell a left-hand hitter
look out and wendell just got hit by a
pitch
it's not the right time to retaliate if
that's what you're trying to do
on the yankee side i'm not sure that
makes sense at all no warnings have been
issued yet
outside ball four and that's been the
best offense for the race today has been
the walk
and now the bases are full with two outs
kevin smith
coming to the plate swinging a ground
ball toward third or shella can't get it
it goes into left field for a base hit
the rays
take advantage of the free passes and
maybe a misplay from rochelle as well
and take a 5-1 lead here come the
yankees with a hit and a walk
one out and here's gleber torres
grounded sharp to short on a knee a
domestic second one
wendell with a turn to first and they
got him a double play to retire the
yankees
two out and two on and now yoshi
chitsuga the last chance here for the
race to
add on chopped to short torres
makes the out at first and a good job by
heller to work out of trouble
and now the yankees have second and
third with two outs
and that final out is uh rather elusive
right now to jalen beaks and here is
lemayo
and there's a base hit off the bat of le
mayo beautiful cutoff there
by renfrow two runs will score and beaks
cannot
get the final out he will be lifted for
nick anderson
and they do give judge that at bat
coming up as the tying run
as it's now 5-3 tampa bay swing in a
high fly ball
left center field back at it meadows
back as caremeyer
to the wall makes the catch of the raids
win
ray's win ray's win thank you tropicana
field
as it was able to hold there and judge
in the ballpark 5-3
win over the yankees and salvage a split
of this doubleheader